hey guys i'm ryan right i'm marie and
alissa waiting why'd you let why don't
you let her go second no illicit comes
before nevermind you [ __ ] it up we're
gonna watch the trailer night for a
Ratchet and Clank the movie trailer for
it did you guys ever play the game
no I've actually never heard of it I
briefly played one of them I liked the
trailers for them that is about as far
as it one for me you know I have a
rehear and she's in the games sort of
Alyssa here
she's pretty any games you know me I
like games I like games a lot so happy
you guys are here both you know when I
played the one Russian Quint game I
enjoyed it it just got stuck on like
some weird thing with like racing hover
bikes that's fun yeah it was fun I was
10 so have you ever been good at I'd be
doing before yeah a couple actually yeah
yeah like what you know I was really
into Warcraft 2 battlenet when I was 11
oh that's awesome yeah um not really
like an appropriate place I think for an
eleven-year-old no that explains a lot
about you now mm-hmm I'm sorry you had
to do that it's not your fault why you
feel the way you do yeah hate all that
the repression just let it out I mean
the worst part was wouldn't I you know
everybody started using Warcraft 3 I
know exactly where you were talking
about one time I bought a bag of fries
my friend took of Frey without asking me
right yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] this is a serious
thing rather your friends Joe yeah you
[ __ ] don't do that [ __ ] don't
do that [ __ ] you don't [ __ ] start
shooting popcorn so goddamn loud in the
movie theater during the quiet moments
Jerry let's watch this trailer you guys
ready ready
sorry Eddie was born ready already
Oh
it was like a really well-made video
game movie wow dude if this one's the
success we're gonna get so many more
that actually looks really really cool I
recognize the character you know I've
never played the game I've seen the
character but I have never seen anything
beyond that watching that legitimately
makes me want to play the game it looks
like so much fun and I'm totally gonna
see that now that I've seen that trailer
I realized that I never actually have
played the game completely
crash bandicoot not crash bandicoot I
have played Crash Bandicoot I've wave
surfer 64 Jackson Dexter so it's Rock
the dinosaur are you thinking of banjo
kazooie no oh my god Oh banjo kazooie is
so awesome Diddy Kong Adventure dude
Diddy Kong Racing is one of my favorite
games of all time yeah
I prefer Mario Kart I don't know cuz my
old car didn't have talking dinosaurs in
it Mario Kart 64 real fast I do want to
mention about this movie like it does
look like this could change like because
I've always thought like like one movie
one video game movie I'll always want to
see get made at Star Fox I thought it'd
be so cool they leave it like an
animated movie or Star Fox like why
haven't they tried that with movies just
make animated films why not just go for
it and and so Marie I'm still talking
I'm still talking Jesus Christ so one
thing about this franchise about this
about the video game movies like I saw
the Sly Cooper trailer that looks pretty
good too and this one looks good and if
these movies are success like critically
and it'll change the gaming business
forever what is wrong with you that was
the very first video we ever did
together yeah
Wow so anyway ìiî ìiî is awesome for
this kind of coverage
yeah after new to the channel you can
subscribe right here that'd be cool I
dig that we'd all dig that if you like
Alyssa she has her channel right here a
couple this would be crazy yeah yeah if
you're like Marie try to look out for
every once in a while and a video of
ours
hey guys yeah it's a special time of the
video
yes Kristoff you look like an Ewok you
said can I please have a shout-out and
please react to Mortal Kombat X please
well have you know I did react to Mortal
Kombat X and I was satisfied and you
want to shout out my friend well yeah
you guys helped us win the war against
the dark side thank you for that and a
lot of people don't appreciate what you
guys did and they said how is the worst
part of this whole saving the world but
you guys are awesome yeah dude [ __ ] what
makes you guys awesome Bicknell 67
another great video man put me on your
shout out list
screw it say my full name Roger Bicknell
bro it would make my hour we'll start
timing it my friend you are gonna have
the best out of your life hold on hold
on what I feel like we're worth more
than an hour cause yeah can we at least
make like your afternoon like I mean if
you're having a shitty hour you watch a
TV show it's over and all right whatever
Roger I mean is your shoutout you really
did someone hurt all of us T wipe it sir
please please please please cover all
the Transformers trailers that's a lot
of trailers dad give me a shout-out I
know you have done a video on every
trailer but is in all to see all of them
at once that last part didn't make any
sense well type it sir you said please
several [ __ ] times and like we said
before saying please it's merely
underrated so thank you it is it's very
underrated and you know what man you
kind of people deserve a lot of respect
it's true so much out there Murray show
your respect
I respect you if you were a dog I would
scratch you under the chin to show you
that I respect you that would be how I
would demonstrate that I feel like
people would like that too we were here
tired I would do that you go ty I'm
sorry it's just funny to me will my toe
across the line every now and then yes I
know she loves me I kind of like you
you're I think you like me to come over
at Mike hold the camera yeah which you
are horrible I doing my boy you know it
Meg from Family Guy sorry you kid you
did it I got to the point where I feel
bad about what I said to you I'm sorry
I feel really bad right now